just a second just a second this could  be a highly theoretical end game  i think it's here i think it's  just a second we're going to see the  moment where arthur's actually opens his  book and tells you how we're going to  make a draw  okay but the king is cut  cut off yes  the king is very far away the king is  cut off  above  many files there's too many files  all right i'm gonna check it later  yeah i think  it's too many files i think yes yeah  with uh too many files this i think this  already looks like oh he got one by the  way okay what a drama and by the way i  found it i found the positions and the  closest one i'm not sure if you can see  ah it's very close  right  very very familiar positions  uh page 158 59  etc etc etc  edition number four